well let's talk to the secretary of
state for health
matt hancock who joins us now from
central london a very good morning to
you we're going to talk about all the
details of the restrictions
in a moment if we may firstly can i just
put you what sakir stam the leader of
labour party has said which is
when you're bringing in stuff like this
announcing it late night on twitter is
not the way to do it how do you expect
people to be
have any idea what's going on this
morning
well we made the announcement last night
we
are moving quickly in some
circumstances and i think that's very
important
and it's one of the things that when you
face a pandemic like this
it is important uh sometimes to move
quickly if that's what's needed and uh
i'm
i'm i'm pleased that uh andy burnham the
mayor of greater manchester
is uh supporting this action
it's absolutely necessary and
of course we we have to sometimes we
have to move
quickly when we can see the growth of
the of the virus
and i understand the impact of decisions
like these i understand
that this is not the sort of decision
anybody
would would want to take but as we've
seen before it is important
to move quickly because because the
virus
spreads and you've got to make sure that
you do everything you can to keep ahead
of it
these restrictions are to be fair though
a little bit confusing out there the
idea that you can't meet people you you
can't visit homes you can't visit
private gardens but the
pubs aren't closing the hairdressers
aren't closing the people are still
meant to be going to work
it's not clear it's not as clear-cut as
a lockdown why not take it one step
further
well of course you know it is absolutely
crystal clear precisely as you said
uh what the new rules are and we've
brought them in to target specifically
the problems that we've been able to see
through the data because we want to keep
the control of the spread of this virus
we want to do that with the minimal
impact on people's lives i appreciate
these decisions do have
significant impacts on on people's lives
but we want to do it with the minimum
impact
and the evidence shows that the
biggest risk in terms of the spread of
this
virus across this area is household
transmission
when people are going to see each other
in their own uh
in each other's homes when they're not
in a household together
and also visiting our friends and
relatives
actually we're not seeing as much
transmission in terms of people in their
place of work or going to retail or
other
areas and so we are able to uh to
to put in place this specific action
we're
not restricting a travel so people can
still go on holiday from the area
affected for instance
and we're not putting in any
restrictions to work so people can still
go to work but we have seen
a significant increase in the spread of
the virus in this area and
our data from the test and trace system
shows
that that is mostly from household
households meeting each other so that's
why we brought this very specific
measure in
it's absolutely crystal clear what the
measure
is which is that you shouldn't socialize
with people in other households
except in public outdoor places so not
in your own home or your garden you can
go to the pub but
with members of your own uh household
and um and other that applies to other
areas of hospitality as well so the
rules are absolutely crystal clear
we brought them in rapidly because we
had to
and we entirely understand the impact
that this has
forgive me for interrupting i mean you
keep talking about
this being very specific and in some
respects
people can see that it is specific but
perhaps not specific
enough according to others i mean bill
ragg the mp
and graham brady the chair of the 1922
both concerned raising comments on
twitter
about the fact that all ten boroughs in
greater manchester which was areas that
obviously they represent are brought in
i mean sir graham's saying you know
trafford
has infections at a low level according
to the latest update there so
if you're being specific why then um
target the all 10 boroughs
well we absolutely looked at what was
the right geography for this
decision unfortunately we have seen an
increase in the number of cases in
in trafford and we also worked with the
local authority
and the local authorities within greater
manchester
uh including the mayor and
the uh and took the decision
to apply this across the whole of
greater manchester the reason for that
is that
um we've seen these increases across the
board
um but in greater manchester as well as
the other areas that are affected
and also you know the problem was that
we had taken more targeted more specific
local action for instance in in oldham
and blackburn
but the uh but we could see that it was
spreading more widely than that
so we had to take the action that we did
you know everybody can see that
the problem with this virus is it
thrives on the
on the social contact you know that
makes life worth living and so
i i totally understand the the human
impact of this
um but unfortunately that is how the
virus passes on
and it's so important that we keep the
virus under control in this country
especially as we see
you know a rise in the number of cases
in in the rest of the world and this
the spike that we're seeing in the rest
of europe we've always said all along
we'll be vigilant
and we'll take action if necessary and
that's why we took the action
as swiftly that we did
you you've talked about um your lack of
social distancing being responsible
for this um how how much of an impact
has the have the eid celebrations have
do you think is is that a defining
factor
well my heart goes out to our
friends in the muslim community who are
affected by
by this ahead of eid i understand the
impact now where we
i'm incredibly grateful for the work of
imams
locally and other local religious
leaders to put in place
socially um socially distant covert
secure
uh celebrations uh for instance which
they're doing in in
parks uh because outside is safer than
inside
uh but it is important that we at that
people
across the whole community um follow the
social distancing rules and follow these
new rules of not having more than one
household need and by a household of
course we mean
a a group of people who live together in
one
house it does not mean a wider extended
family
and and this is this so this is
important for everybody across the area
it but i also recognize that with
eid celebrations tonight and i i very
much wish our muslim
uh communities eden mubarak tonight
uh it will be different this time and
it's really important that these
new rules are followed in the in the eid
celebrations and across the board
i mean that there has been a problem in
in the areas that
that you've targeted with this and as
you say uh andy burnham
agrees with you on that but but we know
that the
our figure we've had this drilled into
us by you and the prime minister and
others that the our figure
is so important when we're hearing that
that
that reproduction rate is 1.04 in the
southwest 1.02
in the south east and under one still
in the northwest it begs the question
whether you think
even if it hasn't been taken up until
now which it hasn't whether you think
there is going to have to be further
action
in the southwest and indeed in the
capital at south east and indeed in the
capital
itself in the coming weeks i mean is
that looking like a possibility
well we've demonstrated that we're
prepared to take the action that's
necessary to keep people safe
you know that was true in leicester when
we took action there
and we're taking much more localized
action in in hundreds of different
locations across right across the
country
and we are seeing in some parts of the
country that increase in the
in the number of of cases
and we take action where where we need
to
now in the southwest and the southeast
of england
thankfully the number of cases is much
much lower
and so we haven't had to take this sort
of action but
but we don't shy away from taking it
wherever it's necessary
we of course would rather not because of
the impact that it has on people's lives
i get that
but we we're prepared to if that's
needed
look when it comes to these specific
areas and
indeed looking at what we may have to do
in the coming weeks and months what is
the government strategy
now when it comes to to covid19 because
previously
it was a very clear strategy of
protecting the nhs
are we at a point now where that is
still the goal
or you know have we moved forward to
eradicating the virus
well we've been very very clear about
that and in and
you know this action is part of the
strategy for keeping the virus right
down you know we brought it
we brought the number of uh cases right
down
we've where we've seen an increase we've
acted we want to act
locally as locally as possible i
appreciate that this is
bigger than a local area uh in um you
know apart across
uh parts of the north of england but we
are
we want to take as local action as uh
possible
um but the the strategy is really clear
which is to
get the virus down to hold the rates of
of
spread down whilst allowing for as much
freedom and return to the things that
make life worth living as we possibly
can
and that's the that's the strategy it's
really clear
this action is part of that uh it means
that
you know we've been able to free up
things where that's been
possible but also you know where we've
seen
the uh the spread especially due to the
uh the household to household
transmission uh then
then we're prepared to take the action
that's needed to keep everybody safe
you